[Musik]
für den papst und den glauben machen sie
alles soldaten des reichsten landes
beschützen dem papst der vom anderen
ende der welt her kommt jede party in
ihren uniformen stellen sich jedem nicht
gutgläubigen in den weg sie sind
abkömmlinge gefürchteter kriegs kurven
aus den tiefsten alpentälern das ist
bereit wäre wenn sie ernst gilt für die
heilige vater ist da alles ohne zögern
und sorgt wiederum glaubt dass man den
seit juni bereits um ist beteiligt
wenn nötig lassen sie sich tot schlagen
[Musik]
papa francesco ist ein alptraum für die
schweizergarde
er reiht sich an kein
sicherheitsdispositiv der papst geh viel
zu offen auf die menschen zu
[Applaus]
jorge mario bergoglio der argentinier
liebt fußball tango und würde lieber bus
fahren statt limousine in anlehnung an
den heiligen franz von assisi wenn sich
der papst franziskus denn er wünscht
sich eine arme kirche für arme menschen
[Musik]
dem utrecht aids kranken zu ostern die
füße
ist er noch mensch oder ist ja schon ein
heiliger spezielles so dass so eine
persönlichkeit wird jedoch daran dass
uli hoeneß präsident kann wenn man kann
aber den aufstand der federung das macht
spezielle komisches ist einen ehebruch
von einer person ja und dann für mich
selbst ein verändertes team also im
islam für ihn das letzte mal emst galt
es am 13
mai 1981
[Applaus]
diese bilder sehen sich die gardisten
immer wieder an
der polnische papst wird wieder
geschossen obwohl sich
schweizergardisten schützen auf ihn
werfen
die autonome giro-starter della città
del vaticano interpretiert man auch so
christoph hesse in christus das sehen
würde
der neue papst stellt jeden popstar in
den schatten
an diesem regnerischen sonntag morgen
werden 100000 platzkarten für die
audienz ausgegeben
von den zuschauern aus gesehen links vom
papa mobil sind sie viele schweizer
gardisten rechts die vatikanische
gendarmerie die beiden kurs sind
konkurrenten
ich mag mir gar nicht vorstellen was
passiert wenn etwas passiert ein neuer
tag das bodenpersonal des lieben gottes
rüstet sich für die nächste schlacht auf
sechs tage woche
für viele war die sonderrechte in der
kantine geht er jeden tag ein bild von
kardinal schiene vorbei der kardinal aus
dem wallis kalt von 500 jahren als das
schlachtross des papstes
er hat das soll dafür sozusagen die
schweizergarde begründet damit die
schmucke uniform nicht begleitet wird
tragen die gardisten blauen schürzen
beim morgenessen sonntagstalk wie zu
hause in der ostschweiz
patrick sonderegger erreicht gerade das
erforderliche gardemaß von 174 cm
umso exakter erfüllte die anderen
voraussetzungen für einen schweizer
gardisten katholisch militärdienst
tauglich ledig die helle barriere müssen
sie für zwei jahre verpflichte zu einem
monatslohn von rund 1000 franken nebst
kostenlos aus der lohn kann es nicht
sein der die jungen schweizer hier er
zieht der pfefferspray ist ihre einzige
keule napster hellebarde tragen die
uniformierten artisten keine waffen auf
sich
wie viele offiziere der schweizergarde
suchen jeden meter auf dem riesigen
petersplatz ab 120 mann stark ist die
kleinste armee der welt
die gendarmerie ist die vatikanische
polizei die zweite wachmannschaft des
papstes ihr gehören nur italiener an
für einmal haben die vierschrötigen
eidgenossen die schmucken uniformen als
die modebewussten römer der neue papst
sie tausende von pilgern an fast jeden
sonntag füllt sich der platz hat sich
sonderegger ist erst ein paar tage vor
der wahl des neuen papstes in die garde
eingetreten
im irak standen sind heinz weiss selber
mit dem papst und den auch eine erste
hält den studiengang denn auch einer der
stars heißt vorwärts marsch da ist im
moment tut recht nervös bestehen aber
nach einem baustopp haben ja vorbei
gelaufen ich waren ziemlich frisch ch da
musste ich mich im moment da ich nicht
jeder irgendwie herrn sie decken was ich
ihnen denn wolfgang oder bürgerbuch
zuerst einen gerne gesehen habe wie auch
das bringt viele studierende schon auch
gerne chinesisch einfach da herrschte
betrieb installiert das
wirtschaftsumfeld gemüse
ja und danach stehen die entstand im
ersten abschnitt der ashanti
der gott immer früh zu gefällt mir sehr
wenn er mit dem rollstuhl gängigen mit
der behinderten lud umgangen stadt alle
tatsachen da darf man immer mehr immer
mehr heißen tores das er gemacht werde
man aber natürlich gern
[Musik]
pabst francesco kommt wie er selbst sagt
vom anderen ende der welt her und
hellebarde sonderegger kommt hinter den
ostschweizer bergen her
der gelernte schreiner war bis vor
kurzem ein stubenhocker
erst hier in rom hat er etwas von der
großen welt mitbekommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
diese wir eine dekadente
der herr lässt euch mit diesen regen
segnet der papst zu den quatsch nassen
bildung und die vikare humor ich bin
schnell drama von wollen sehr sexy hatte
ben afflecks arbeitet sich langsam
alltag weil meine wohnte bewohner bekam
sie
das komische ist dass ich einfach für
meine der prüfung wo einer voll im lande
nicht ist einer großstadt wie uns mal
aussteigen lassen schafft darf neben dem
palast wohnen
der kleine helle bambi erhält riesen
stücke auf seinen großen chef papa
francesco sei kein wasser prediger und
heimlicher weintrinker
wenn es nicht überheblich tönen würde
würde der kleine hellebarde gerne sagen
francesco ist eigentlich ein großer
bruder für mich papst
[Musik]
der vatikan ist einer der kleinsten
souveränen staaten der welt so groß wie
nur gerade 40 fußballfelder 750 menschen
leben in den mauern darunter die
schweizergardisten
neuerdings müssen die gardisten auch
noch das vatikan eigene hotel bewache
darin wohnt papst francesco er weigert
sich im papstpalast zu residieren
so prunkvoll für den papst der aus den
armen 4 punkt von buenos aires kommt
ist roland christian musik foto lügen
touristen nach oben schlagen
foto und constanze sie auf distanz
noch in sieben haben wir machen auch der
vorwurf gemacht
[Musik]
feldmann
eine parade christan macht stunde lang
dienst und den vatikan alleingängen
[Musik]
august
was
[Musik]
kameraj in campanet nicht speziell
auch roland christian wir diese tage
seinen eid auf die fahne ablenken
für den letzten schliff sind die zwei
gar die eigenen italienischen schneit
zuständig sie übernehmen hier in der
fremde für viele christen die rolle die
zu hause die mama ausfüllt abwenden und
auskühlen hauptmann bachmann bei der
befehlsausgabe für einen auslandseinsatz
der garde
wer was macht wer begleitet werden sich
die hellebarden werden verladen
es geht raus aus dem vatikan der papst
feiert heute abend einen gottesdienst
zwei kilometer weit in italien draußen
darum passiert die verschiebung der
schweizer garten mit römischer polizei
eskorte schließlich handelt es sich um
eine ausländische armee um eine
bewaffnete armee in 30 artisten und die
polizisten genießen es sichtlich im
stossverkehr auf der linken straßenseite
durch rom zu brausen vorbei am kolosseum
in die partie karner eigenen klawe santa
maria maggiore
so lala sie lassen
[Musik]
zu ihrem burgwerben heute die chorknaben
nicht mehr kastriert damit sie ihre
hohen engelsstimmen mit dem stimmbruch
nicht verlieren
er zahlt sich also doch etwas geändert
in der katholischen kirche in den
letzten 100 jahren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kann der neue papst die hoffnung wir
geweckt hat einlösen
viele baustellen der kirche warten auf
ihn
er wahrt die league skandal die
aufarbeitung des skandals um petra ssten
priester und auch die rolle der frauen
in der katholischen kirche
jorge mario bergoglio ist nicht mehr der
jüngste
trotzdem gottes beste mann ein haus weg
zu spielen der die chance nicht
vertreten darf
[Musik]
sein 127
daher gibt es in seinen im schlaf
[Musik]
frauen die sprache nach außen hat sich
mit francesco verändert mit einfachen
worten und gesten hat der papst viele
menschen für sich gewonnen
er hat eine unbezahlbare pr offensive
für die kirche gestartet darum mögen die
staunenden die dogmatische starrheit und
allerlei skandale der kirche vergessen
unsere helle barriere glauben
bedingungslos an ihn aber anstrengend
ist er schon dieser glauben dramatische
wolken über der hauptkirche der
katholischen christenheit der sechste
mai ist jedes jahr der heldenhaftes der
tag der schweizer gardisten
rap ist um für die einen symbol des
kirchlichen reichtums für die andern der
ort wo sie 147 schweizergardisten für
den papst totschlagen ließen um so die
roma also bei der plünderung von rom vor
500 jahren
[Musik]
langsam rutsch patrick sonderegger das
herz in die hose
kann er die eidesformel heute noch
auswendig
was muss es sagen wenn er dem papst
gegenüber steht
[Musik]
die sonneberger sie mit 56 weiteren fans
ihres sohnes aus dem sanktgallischen
dürfe nie kassiert angereist
[Musik]
es ist kurz vor pfingsten der heilige
geist kommt noch nicht
dafür kommt der chef der besten armee
der welt zu besuch beim chef der
kleinsten aller welt bundespräsident
wulff
notabene reformiert wurde eigentlich
keine auslandsbesuche machen
am festtag der schweizer gardisten
drängte sich aber zum papst
bei der herr auch an diesem tag mit
regen segnet findet die
vereidigungszeremonie in der
audienzhalle des papstes statt
besonders vater im publikum christen
gute christen und vorbildliche soldaten
zu sein sei auch heute gepaart mit der
botschaft unseres neu entschieden herrn
papst franziskus als bedingungslose
freunde christi nicht nur werkzeuge alle
die ihr tagtäglich begegnet zu sein
sondern vor allem freunde des papstes
für den ihr bereit seid selbst den
blutzoll zu leisten
[Musik]
die mittelalterliche zeremonie lässt
einen fast vergessen dass das was die
gardisten schwören auch blutiger ernst
werden kann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
35 neue helaba die leisten dieses jahr
den hut auf die fahne
höhepunkt ist der anschließende besuch
bei papa francesco
patrick sander eckert der kleine bach
stellt seinen papst motoren vater vor
noch nie hat es ein papst gewagt sieht
franziskus zu nennen immerhin ist franz
von assisi die nummer zwei in der ewigen
beliebtheitsskala bergkirchen als
prediger der armut also eine anmaßung
dieses heiligen vaters für die gardisten
aus dem reichsten land der welt ist das
so dass so gewöhnungsbedürftig für sie
und jede verwandten stand die
verteidigung im vordergrund
wer es wir sind trainer gelaufen und
habe sich noch nie erlebt und ich es
besonders warm oder vergebenen das heißt
dass ihre so laut dem betreiber 65 jahre
die möglichkeit eigentlich ja das machen
weil sie dazu
und wie sind sie denn genau aber maxime
so grüne dass er im sind traummann
können auch viele und wissen dass sie wo
sie dem coach gegenüber gestanden sind
schneeschuhwandern oder körper ablaufen
ist als man in älterer vorstellen
strafräumen darfst extrem freude für
momente weil für sie sich natürlich
speziell system parts zu vernichten
gesehen und persönlich reden mit themen
oder und wassili tusow
[Musik]
ja bestätigt dass spezielle vorsteht ist
verfolgt der schon wieder war ich
einfach im hinterhof kritisches einfach
wissen
junos software rüstungen werden wieder
abgegeben nicht abgegeben wie die angst
der mütter die siegerlisten da wäre
gutgläubigkeit ein schwacher trost
[Musik]
[Applaus]